welcome back to New rockers I'm Jessica
Clemens covering for Eric Voss while
he's out on fraternity Le and today I'm
breaking down the fifth episode of what
if Captain Carter fought the Hydra
stomper this episode is actually a
sequel from the first episode of the
last season but follows up from the
finale when IU sent the heroes back to
their specific timelines after they
finished cleaning up his mess this
episode has so many call outs to the MCU
and surprises us with a little snippet
of another episode 1602 they did an
amazing job on this episode all in all
though so touching and nothing I like
more than two women in MCU kicking it
and kicking ass so let's jump into this
episode with a little more Easter eggs
and details you might have missed and
maybe clear up some confusion as to like
timeline stuff because so you right now
I would both but first we have some what
if inspired merch over at nerd ride.
shop we have Echo gear Loki gear and
Christmas for January gear go check out
our awesome merch over there it's a
great way to support the channel but
also look fresh as hell while doing it
okay let's jump in we opened during the
Battle of New York in the first Avengers
movie a shitari warrior screams on top
of a car but is immediately blasted in
the face by Natasha who is still voiced
by Lake Bell she's not saved by Captain
America though she's saved by Captain
Carter we're still following the Great
Adventure that is Captain Carter from
last season's what if Peggy Carter
became the first avenger we saw Peggy
and then we saw Steve in the Hydra
Pursuit before she was shot into the
future meeting Clint and Nick Fury a few
days before Loki got there we know it's
a continuation from that episode because
we watch who mentions at the beginning a
little later in the episode this is a
sequel and also we're picking up where
the finale post credit scene left us
like Captain America Peggy was greeted
in the future by Shield next we know
she's fighting alongside Natasha calling
her a new friend so this must be the
first mission Steve was handed by Fury
and the first Avengers movie unlike the
weird sexual tension we normally get
between these two we get a nice best
friend Duo from Peggy and Nat Peggy uses
her shield to protect Natasha just like
cap does in the movies protecting her
from falling debris this is even around
that same scene where we see Natasha has
the chitauri weapon and she almost used
it on Steve during the movie Peggy then
Boomerang throws the shield to the
enemies then catches it nice little
trick I picked up in Berlin Captain
America wasn't really like fighting in
Berlin until Civil War but Captain
Carter last season was kicking ass and
surprising herself with this new
Boomerang effect then Natasha does the
same sick ass combo saying she had a
weird childhood in mascow as we know
Natasha was a child of the Red Room
working under drov and his Weirs that's
how he says it they're all forced to
live fake lives spy fight kill and
endure non-consensual hysterectomies
it's an awful existence but this
Avengers team up is already very
different from the first movie Yes we
still have Natasha Clint Thor and Tony
but we also have Captain Carter and I
think that's wasp in the Ant-Man suit
the design is the same as the Ant-Man
and wasp suit but it's red and black now
instead of that dark Navy we saw in that
movie though we don't see Bruce Banner's
Hulk Banner is still alive and a
scientist in this time Nat recommended
reaching out to him for help he's just
not fighting in this team because a he's
just a normal scientist maybe at this
time or B he doesn't want to Peggy leads
the team like Steve did executing a plan
of attack then she launches Natasha off
her Shield like we saw them do as well
shot for shot Natasha grabs the shitari
aircraft and takes off Peggy and Natasha
face off with Loki and his punchable
face and we cut to the intro we've been
getting with watu I'll be honest when I
was watching this episode and I saw
Rachel Weiss's name I was like who wait
what then it said Elizabeth Olson I said
wait what it's a little bit of a spoiler
seeing those names at the beginning of
the credits but I was stoked nonetheless
watatu opens the episode again I don't
do sequels normally what's the point of
revisiting the story when there are
infinite stories to be told we got this
snippet of audio from the trailer
teasing into a sequel which I like and I
think is funny technically because the
episode where he interfered too much was
basically also a sequel it was two parts
but you know I guess he did say he
normally doesn't do a sequel so either
way the Watcher is clearly inspired by
Peggy and wants not to be inspired by
this wonderful amazing iconic woman also
she jumps into multivers madness for 5
minutes and get slaughtered just give my
girl a full-on episode or you know give
her another series whisper whisper Wu is
shuffling the shards around and we see
Natasha the frost giant Loki and some
faint others reshaped and filling the
Broken Walls one wall he aligns
perfectly sort of locks into place with
a seal of gold then we see scenes from
the fight in Berlin and season 1 and
he's right she's the hero of World War
II a woman ahead of her time but also
literally because they won the war last
season then she jumped into the future U
Glu another piece of time piecing back
the events of the last seasons what if
the Watcher broke his oath in that
episode Ultron Vision was free and
became the number one threat to the
Multiverse aatu then collected a team of
the universe's mightiest you know I
wouldn't say Heroes I would call them
Warriors though without their assistance
the Multiverse would have crumbled in
the end he did return them to the exact
moments they left their realities but
unfortunately Peggy was in the wrong
time since she jumped hers to begin with
she wanted to go back to se butu assured
her that the new time she was in needed
Captain Carter oh someone said that
about me in my time I like the role
reversal also on these two and Captain
America the Winter Soldier Natasha
picked up Steve while running and here
it's Peggy picking up Nat it's also eye
opening to see how the transition for
Peggy looked versus Steve he was kind of
unyielding but Peggy's like get in loser
we're going shopping she even makes a
not that she doesn't like running in
circles like Steve always did in the
2014 movie the mission was to rescue
hostages on a hijack Shield ship called
the lumian star however Nat was saving
Shield Andel while Steve was really
rescuing the hostages it created a
hostile atmosphere because trust is key
and that's important to note because in
this episode it wasn't hostages or Intel
it was Steve Rogers and the hydro somper
which I guess you could say that Steve
in the hydro stomber was a hostage and
also Intel but you know what I mean it
was wasn't manipulative or like an
untrustworthy tactic Nat did it out of
friendship the Pirates were after the
hydro Stompers suit that home Steve
Rogers Back in the Day little Steve was
in the hydro stomper as himself in this
reality he's basically Bucky so we
learned from theur later that Bucky and
Steve created their own two-man Army and
destroyed every Hydra based on Earth
that was until the last one killed Steve
in Argentina in 1953 as we know after
the war a lot of Nazis ran to Argentina
and hiding so something major here took
place at that time as a note when
researching I found out in 1953 Hydra
was still scheming to disable Iz the
world using people in power to really
shake things up Christof was in power as
the first Secretary of the Central
Committee of the Communist Party of the
Soviet Union organized by Hydra
essentially in the most heartbreaking
way Peggy and Steve just cannot catch a
break in this timeline she's turned into
his number one enemy but for now we
don't know about the future a weird
thing about when you watch me in these
videos is you only ever see me awake but
you got to know I'd rather be asleep
sleep is the best and if you want to
make your sleep even better you should
use pillow pillow is a sleep tracking
app that can help analyze your sleep
sleeping habits and steer you towards
healthier sleepier sleep if you have an
Apple Watch pillow will start
automatically when you doze off if not
just hit a button on your iPhone or iPad
to get going pillow scientifically back
sleep analysis will track the stages of
your sleep your sleeping heart rate
blood oxygen levels respiratory rate and
environmental audio levels pillow can
even wake you up a few minutes earlier
than your alarm if it senses that you
are in a lighter sleep stages that means
waking up less groggy and more refreshed
plus pillow has a bazillion relaxing
sounds that help you fall asleep which
yes please I need that Urban rainfall
even if it's actually raining out I want
to hear water on the sidewalk as it pass
out for new pillow subscribers use code
new rockstars 20 to get 20% off pillow
premium and start your free 7-Day trial
using the link in the description below
Nat makes RoboCop reference and yes
Steve is like RoboCop just not the good
one the big bulky one that keeps killing
people because he's broken the Hydro has
been upgraded of course since we last
saw it before the finale post credit
scene and now has red accents and a red
star for Russia just like Bucky's arm
there's also a number 88 on his body
which could be a reference to Tales of
suspense the comic run that first
introduced Peggy Carter but in issue
8889 Bucky Barn shows up as a robot like
we're sort of seeing here when he was
fighting alongside Peggy his eyes were
blue later turning yellow in shock Now
red because he's clearly evil it shoots
bullets and it's built like a rotary
cannon on the cuffs and shoots missiles
originally all Steve was really doing
was smashing things and shooting these
blue blasts of energy he's also like the
new Crimson Dynamo suit that turned up
in Moscow Peggy throws her Shield at the
hydro stomper and it reveals Steve's
face he's just technically older and has
facial hair whereas Bucky just straight
up looked exhausted and have longer hair
and winner soldier Steve hit Bucky with
the shield and ripped off his mask in a
sick ass flip instead of Peggy signature
take it to the Dome move he shoots off
the ship and now they've released the
winter Hydro stomper when Steve sets off
those missiles and it's floating in
front of the Moon all of it just looks
like the hydro logo I don't know if that
was like meant to happen if it was a
creative Choice an homage but I noticed
that Peggy's pissed at Nick like Steve
was for lying which we know he
technically like didn't do like last
time this time he was also fed wrong
Intel believing he was dead and as we
even saw in episode 2 there were rumors
that Bucky was alive as an agent for
Russia just like Steve was around as a
hydro stomper in this time also it's
very important to note that Fury just
confirmed that there is a big foot in
that timeline in our universe we just
got that guy on the wall and wherewolf F
night in this story though another turn
of events it wasn't the Soviet Union
Hydra the Red Room actually found and
use the hydromer as a weapon the idea
feels so easy and so good and I don't
know why he didn't like try to put this
together in the comics Bucky was turned
into an assassin by the Soviets and
worked for Russia's Department X where
he ended up being trained at the Red
Room and did the the Black Widow o
program as a trainer where he met
Natasha for the first time and they
eventually fell in love so it's not like
it hasn't been done before but I don't
know why I didn't think about it and an
even bigger news an older Bucky is here
still voiced by Sebastian stand just in
an old man's voice and I'm truly
obsessed with it he's alive in this
universe as the secretary of state so
he's our Thunderbolt Ross this man says
this surely you understand that the
sovian aid package is generous
considering considering it doesn't cover
Hospital schools or New Roads fix it I
won't have a country torn apart by Civil
War because we didn't do the right thing
in such a weird way I think he dropped
an Easter egg on themselves so Bucky
responds to the sovian aid packages
alongside mentioning just the phrase
Civil War during Civil War Thunderbolt
Ross enacted the sovian Accords after
the Avengers caused so much damage
saving the day all the goddamn time this
way they'll just be monitored must get
approval before joining in any fights
this is all named after the events after
sovia instead it looks like Bucky
created a sovian Aid package to fix the
damages then in comes Brock rumo voiced
by the same man who played him in the
movies Frank gria Bucky tells him he may
be old but he's punched on and shared
beard with aliens it's a reminder that
he fought Hydra forever but the alien
one is new to me he's the Secretary of
State though and this is the MCU so he's
probably had some kind of diplomatic
meetings with alien adjacent beings on
Earth Steve's mission was to allegedly
kill Bucky our secretary of state Below
in the belly of Shield we see the little
Shield worker bees going away at it
similar to how they always look in MCU a
giant map of the world is on the screen
nothing too specific they always include
this circle with atmospheric gibberish
like Tony has in his Iron Man suits then
Nat locks onto the hydro stomper and we
get a series of Random alphabetical
letters and numbers sizing him up then
the target locks Bucky stands between
the plane and the hydromer protecting
Steve he says this Steve would be stupid
enough to do the same for me Bucky
actually saved Steve a lot more in the
MCU but I'd argue only physically and
usually from things he started in the
first place but he's right Steve would
do this and literally lost friends
colleagues and career protecting and
fighting for Bucky in Another Universe
Bucky says let's get a drink like old
days and it gets him for a moment that
he's like psych luckily Peggy shows up
smashes through a million ceilings and
into the air still fighting Nat pulls up
in what looks like the Quin yet and
catches them that takes them the saint
kill to Scotland and just like Shield
I've never heard of this place before
it's revealed here that the suit is
preserving his age and body and if they
remove it he dies each time he activates
it it kills him a little bit inside like
Jane Foster with me Peggy says Steve
might be stuck in some frozen prison and
Frozen carbonite and she's seen Star
Wars which reminds me how Steve writes
down all the new things he needs to try
Peggy's already immersed in it black
Widow says this before I join Shield I
spent 5 days in a Hungarian sewer
tracking down and killing the head of
the red room are you certain you killed
him I mean I stabbed him in the cored
artery with a cork screw so yeah I think
I did firstly if you watch Harley
Quinn's animated show Lake Bell as
poison ivy is the rated R version of
Lake Bell as Black Widow it made me
realize how similar the two characters
are and should be secondly we learned
that she killed the leader who I presume
is Draco which our Black Widow tried
doing in our universe yet this one
succeeded on more brutal murder Steve is
brought back and he says he owes Peggy a
date which he said right before she
disappeared at the end of episode one
last season it's also like their whole
thing they say it all the time they just
need to dance you know back in the day
there was nothing that they could do but
dance we love dancing the number on the
side of the Quin jet says 42 Shield
which could be a reference to a lot of
things one Agents of Shield comics issue
number 42 where Fury takes on Hydra two
it could be 42 the prison from Earth's
Mightiest Heroes it kind of resembles
the new flying Red Room it was a prison
but also an abduction holding space like
the Red Room three it could be the
answer to everything like the hitch's GU
of Galaxy we're at the sovian military
base where in the '90s the Red Room
moved in and made it look like a basic
American town now Peggy share another
exchange but this time about John melon
Camp the real musician who absolutely
makes dad rock as Peggy puts it this
little town is giving like high
evolutionary meet hex view meets Doom
towns it's so eerie and creepy I don't
know if I like it but it's also the best
place to have a crazy fight scene
without damaging real innocent people
the music plays that Peggy and Steve
finally dance to in the movies and I
hate and love this song it sort of
haunts me then they're taking out of
this lovely moment when widow bites
electrocute them we've seen these things
before in Black Widow and it takes a
fullon army to take down Peggy Carter
it's like watching and King Kong get
taken down in the 2005 one then we see
the new flying Red Room just like the
one we saw in Black Widow the bottom of
this one has a triangle though where the
other one had like a circle Target the
new Red Room leader is Molina voiced and
still played by Rachel Weiss we are
winning and in this story we keep that
Trope that it's Nat's mom the plan was
to lure Captain Carter and study her
Molina makes note of Captain Carter's
movie she meant the musical which like
Steve Rogers the musical I'm sure is
very British and very fun the next
sequence of shots we get especially with
the widows chasing that is so good
they're all like a assassin ballerinas
which I guess they are trained in Molina
uses her history with Natasha to take
her down an injury on her bike which she
got when she was in the third grade we
saw her using her bike at the beginning
of Black Widow so we know that she
actually likes riding this scene is like
the one in black widow when the girls
are jumping Nat she also uses the same
Red Widow bites to take them down in a
Saturn of events Peggy puts down her
shield and she admits she was using
fighting to distract her from how much
she miss Steve she doesn't care if he
kills her as long as she's going with
him which is wild as hell girl do not do
that do not go down for this man she
knows his only way out is to save her by
destroying the Red Room and blowing it
up from the inside the Red Room comes
crashing down just like it did in the
movie with pieces of debris all over the
place U watches as the town becomes a
true Doom Town luckily there's no
Thunderbolt Ross here just Bucky who
understands what's going on so now Nat
and Peggy decide to search for Steve who
might still be out there and worth
saving and then this happens what the
hell is
this hey Natasha Peg Peggy Peg where are
you that's
a good question Peggy opened her eyes to
16002 with Nick Fury and the Scarlet
Witch AKA Wanda Merlin my like weird
fantasy cosplaying just came out of my
brain I love 1602 they need her help
protecting the queen just like they did
in the comics and I'm so excited to dive
into this episode it's such a weird
comic run it's so fun also Wanda wasn't
that great in the comics in 1602 kind of
a baddie but Nick Fury isn't a baddie so
I just need to know what's going on and
we'll get into that the next episode we
see it and that's it for my breakdown
episode 5 what if Captain Carter fought
the Hydra stomper follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu Clemens follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching I'll see you
[Music]
later